if you suddenly had the power to
brutally murder anyone you wanted to
what would you do you'll be able to kill
anyone just by writing down their name
and soon you'll be known as a God among
men I'm going to break down the mistakes
made what you should do and how to beat
the book of death in Death Note this
genius has no idea that he's about to
brutally murder hundreds of thousands of
people light here is your above average
high school student living in a city
full of murderers and violence one day
in class he notices a notebook suddenly
fall from the sky and he goes to pick it
up seeing the words death note written
on the top he opens the book and
discovers the two main instructions the
human whose name is written in this note
shall die and the writer must have the
person's face in their mind for the
death to happen within 40 seconds of
writing the person's name their death
will happen and unless the cause of
death is specified the person will die
of a heart attack light thinks this book
is a sick joke but he takes it home to
study it further not realizing that this
book will soon turn him into the most
horrifying serial killer in the world
later that night he stares at the book
and wonders what to do with it when
suddenly on the TV he sees a live news
report of a murderer holding people
hostage suddenly he gets curious to find
out if this book is real light writes
down the name of the murderer he sees on
the news into his book and he waits 40
seconds pass by and that's when the news
reports that the murderer holding these
people hostage has just died from a
heart attack and has now become light's
first victim as he realizes that this
Death Note is real
okay this is insane because what the
light just found is something known as a
Death Note a mysterious black notebook
that can kill anyone as long as the user
knows both the target's name and face
and inside the notebook is a set of
horrifying rules aside from the first
two as we've seen the writer must have
the person's face and their mind when
writing their name therefore people
sharing the same name will not be
affected and after writing the cause of
death details of the death should be
written within the next 6 minutes and 40
seconds and judging from this City's
insanely high crime rate and how much of
a goody two shoes light is it's no
wonder that this teenager decided to
play God but here's the thing at the
rate that light has now begun to kill
criminals killing within his native
country means that it's only a matter of
time before the police figure out that
something is going on meaning that if
Lloyd wants to be the sneakiest Japanese
killer of all time then he can't afford
to think small the death note's powers
are nearly Limitless and can work on a
global scale and it's clear that light
has access to the internet therefore
wouldn't it make more sense if light
just chose to kill criminals located
worldwide and in countries away from
Japan for starters he could have simply
gone to search on government sites like
the lapd's official most wanted list and
County Probation list which by the way
provides the list of criminals wanted
within the region local to that area
along with the details of their crime
and a clear picture of their face and
light could have easily replicated this
method with any such list provided
online and also for example killing one
person in Bangkok Thailand and another
one in Indonesia right after would have
lessened the chances that the police
would think that the Killer is Japanese
as opposed to what light has now begun
to do which is to not only kill within
his native country but within his local
area lights god-like complex means that
it's only a matter of time until his
silliness comes back to fudge him up
light is shocked but also increase
incredibly intrigued and he decides to
test out the Death Note one more time
just to be sure and he gets a taste for
the Bloodshed that night he goes to his
school's weekly prep class and he tries
to find his first victim noticing some
bullies he follows them and he sees them
troubling this girl he then writes down
this one Bully's name in his book
moments later light sees this kid get
brutally crushed by an incoming truck
dying in the exact same way as life
wrote it down and his death note he
immediately runs back home and begins
furiously writing down hundreds of names
in his death note not wanting to kill
innocent people oh no no no no he wants
to kill the scum of society so light
only writes down the names of publicly
known criminals suddenly he notices the
horrifying red eyes of an unknown
creature appear in his room and light
freaks out this creature named ryuk
tells him that he is a Shinigami also
known as a god of death and he has
appeared from another realm he tells
light that since he draw dropped his
death note into the human world the book
now belongs to whoever picks it up and
anyone who touches the death note will
be able to see the Shinigami owner of
that Death Note ryuk then warns light
that as a god of death he is neither
light's enemy nor his ally ryuk then
tells light that he's never seen a human
kill so many people like this before so
quickly and light then reveals to him
his horrifying master plan to rid the
world of all evil and to make his City a
place for only good people a few days
later the world's leaders hold a
conference to discuss the recent death
of criminals happening all over the
world desperate for answers they begin
to suspect that all these deaths are in
fact murders suddenly this man enters
the room and puts them on the phone with
the world's greatest detective a man
known as L and this mysterious man then
tells this group that he thinks that
despite the recent murders happening all
over the world he suspects that the
murderer is in Japan and tells them that
he has a plan to prove his Theory one
week later the killings have gotten
worse and light discovers that the
internet has begun to realize that
someone is killing all these criminals
and the world begins to call this person
Kira suddenly he sees a police detective
appear on the news and this person
declares to the world that he will stop
Kira no matter what light getting cocky
but also slightly irritated at the man
sees his name appear on the TV he writes
it down in his death note and he kills
this man live on national TV he laughs
at his god-like powers but that's when
The Real L Reveals His mysterious voice
and state that the man who just died on
TV was just a prisoner and that this
news broadcast was only broadcasted to
people in certain areas of Japan El used
this as a test meaning that L has now
figured out that not only is Kira in
Japan but that he is in the Kanto region
of Japan shocking light to the bone as
he realizes that he's just been played
come on light you're killing me light
right now has been on a Killing Spree
since he first got his powers but there
is one key difference here while he has
the powers of a god at the end of the
day he's still a snotty-nosed little
teenager human which means that there
are limitations to his powers and that
he's been acting way too careless
without a care in the world from the
start and he's been abusing his powers
to the point where his actions have
finally caused him in getting his
location discovered if he really wanted
to be judge jury and executioner the god
of his world then maybe this God should
not have allowed his location to have
been discovered L is known as the
world's greatest detective but even if
light didn't know this at the very
beginning when he saw this guy on the TV
light is brilliant but sometimes
Brilliance lines you to the truth and
the truth is he should have maybe
thought about his actions and what would
have happened if he killed this guy live
on TV he's been killing an awful lot of
pests around Japan and the world if I
was light I would show him how a pro
does it I wouldn't kill this guy who
says he's ill on TV oh no no no I would
analyze Elle's moves for a period of
time before offing him whether is no
general public profile of a serial
murderer the study of Neuroscience has
identified certain common traits with
serial murderers including impulsivity
and the need for control and this is
just from what light demonstrated right
now by his lack of control over his
emotions and getting baited by L now
knowing who he's up against despite
lights insane powers and smarts his need
to be in charge makes whatever actions
he takes personal whereas for L for now
solving this crime is simply an
objective and not personal yet the days
passed by and the police start analyzing
the time of death of Kira's victims
noticing that the deaths happened
between 4 pm to 2 A.M on weekdays and
any time during the weekend making the
police suspect that Kira may be in fact
be a student and that's when life's
father mustache man comes home and ryuk
realizes that light's dead is the head
of police and the head of Kira task
force wow that's a shocker light hacks
into his dad's police laptop and then
light is granted access to the entire
police database and Kira suddenly
changes his tactics and writes down the
names of 23 scum of the earth people in
advance set to die over the next 24
hours one day passes and Kira's new
tactics begin to confuse the police and
they start to doubt that Kira is a
student however L suspects that these
new tactics by Kira are too much of a
coincidence and now thinks that this
serial killer might have access to
police information what is this this is
insane light is not only a goody little
Two-Shoes serial killer but has a dad
who is leading the Kira task force and
big brain light hacking and getting
access to the investigation is as much
of a negative as it is a positive what
light is planning to do right now does
seem like a great idea to make Elle
think that Kira in fact does have access
somehow to the police and is keeping
tabs on the investigation his plan will
be to force Elle into investigating the
police and by being investigated by L
will know that eventually piss off the
police who find out that the guy they're
working with is investigating them and
this will create internal distrust
between the task force and could
ultimately buy light even more time to
do his naughty little Deeds but here's
the thing L has already identified that
Kira is local to Japan and within the
Kanto region and by judging from when
the times he has committed the crimes L
has deduced that Kira May likely be a
student while light may seem smart
trying to create Havoc within the Kira
task force this move of light means that
he is letting L get way too close to him
and won't be long before Elle finds him
or the more likelier option light slips
up and as mentioned before lights ego
and sense of self-worth has already made
him mess up when it came to killing the
fake elf without a care in the world and
when he thought he could simply begin
murdering people on his off hours from
school I mean come on someone much more
methodical or even more scared of
getting caught would never have done
that and have taken better precautionary
measures from the beginning for instance
that person would have already known not
to set up such an obvious killing
timetable from the very beginning Kira
is letting Elle think that he has some
leads against him because he is so
confident that L will never catch him
and statistically speaking L does have a
lower chance of catching Kira as well
the number of serial killers has
declined since the 1980s so two also has
the number of murder cases been solved
on average due to increased serial
killer expertise serial killers are
getting smarter on how to fool the cop's
plant fake evidence due internet
research and also some detectives in
certain areas are less qualified than
others and also let's not forget the
internet which makes it real easy to
practically find everybody but Kira here
is missing one very important factor
that he could use to get L off of his
back and not risk getting caught in the
process and that has to do with Japan's
insanely low crime rate and the way they
prosecute criminals as of 2011 my good
weeps Japan has a homicide rate of 0.3
per 100
000 people and while America's rate is
4.7 per 100 hundred thousand people but
part of the reason for this is suspects
being held in Japan will often falsely
admit guilt just to end a stressful
interrogation as interrogations in Japan
can hold suspects for up to 23 days
without a charge longer than most other
rich countries would even allow
terrorist suspects to be detained also
access to defense lawyers during this
period is also limited and the
prosecution there is ruthless and
regularly puts pressure on the police to
extract confessions light could use
Japan's harsh crime laws to his
advantage and could pin the Kira murders
onto some random Patsy of his choosing
and while this move may not permanently
get L off of the real Kira's back this
move would likely slow down the overall
progress of the investigation more than
what light is currently trying to do
which is to make Elle investigate the
police and this move comes with added
risk that light will become even more
closely linked to the Kira investigation
because of his dad however there's no
doubt that light's self-inflated sense
of self-worth means that he'd rather
played risky so he can make fun of Al
right under his nose more and more
criminals begin to Die daily and this
starts to horrify the police and they
even begin to quit the Kira task force
one by one scared for their lives
worried that Kira will kill them the
police began to question Elle's
Authority and demand that he Reveals His
identity to them but they don't realize
that L has bigger plans for them as the
FBI from America will soon arrive in
Japan and begin secretly investigating
the Japanese police 141 people have
access to the Kira case which means that
Kira has direct access to at least one
person within the Kira task force and L
begins to narrow down the search and the
clock starts ticking that night ryuk
warns light that somebody is following
him and he begins to wander if the
police have begun to suspect him he
needs to find out the identity of this
stalker and kill him and quickly but
ryukir tells light that he can offer him
a horrifying superpower that will solve
all of his problems ryuk tells light
that if he makes a deal with him he can
obtain the the eyes of a Shinigami which
means he'll be able to see the identity
and lifespan of any human he looks at
and this means that he'll be able to
kill anyone he sees on the spot however
ryuk tells light that if he wants this
horrifying power it'll cost him
something big light asks him just what
exactly that is and ryuk tells him that
it will cost him half half of his
remaining lifespan in exchange for this
power light refuses this deal and tells
ryuk that he is too important to have
his life cut short the following day
Kira tests out some more unique ways of
killing people with the Death Note
killing more prisoners and making them
exhibit some bizarre behaviors before
they die he even makes this one pest
draw a picture on the wall with blood
the second leaving behind an
unexplainable letter and the third
running into a bathroom with all three
of them dying of a heart attack shortly
after news of these deaths reaches out
and he begins to suspect that Kira can
not only kill his victims with a heart
attack but he can manipulate the actions
of his victims before their death he
thinks that Kira is currently testing
the limits of his powers not realizing
that this Bloodshed is about to get a
whole lot worse meanwhile light sits in
his room and looks into the prison
deaths discovering that before his
victim's death he can only control the
actions of his victim up to a certain
point and before they die victims can't
write about the things they don't
already know or couldn't come up with on
their own meaning that Kira can only
control his victims to perform actions
that are reasonable and physically
possible for them to do with this
information in hand light plans his next
move to figure out the identity of the
man following him using this escaped
convict he sees on the news and he
prepares to set his plan in motion the
next day light goes on a date
a date oh that's hilarious anyways the
two lovebirds head into this bus forcing
the guy following them to join them on
the trip later as the bus stops the
escaped convict from last night's news
enters and pulls out a gun and he
threatens to kill everyone here light
then shows his date his were in Down
plan to stop the bad guy and the dude
sitting behind them notices the note he
tells light to sit down saying that
he'll stop the bad guy instead showing
light his FBI badge and revealing to him
his identity this guy's an FBI agent
which means L is now looking at light
directly as a possible suspect life then
purposely drops a ripped out piece of
the Death Note onto the floor and bad
guy notices this and picks it up
touching it he suddenly sees ryuk appear
and begins to freak out shooting at him
terrifying the people on the bus losing
his mind the criminal stops the boss and
tries to run away but that's when he
gets brutally killed in an accident with
each step of this plan happening in the
same way the light rode down in his
death note thinking that light is just a
normal kid the FBI agent tells him to
not tell anyone when they met since he's
meant to be undercover and the two
agreed to keep their meeting a secret
not realizing the light is on to him the
FBI agent walks away and plans to stop
investigating him completely but that
was his and life's biggest mistake okay
this is insane because what Kira did
here was smart he figured out that he
could legitimately control the actions
of someone leading up until their time
of death which means he's just figured
out something huge however him
discovering the identity of this FBI
agent and then likely planning to kill
him means that this kid is still
thinking way too small remember the
Death Note can not only manipulate the
time of death but can also control the
actions of the victims allowing them to
perform actions of whatever is
physically possible for them to do and
this last part is important to write
down instructions for a victim to fly to
France in two hours and then die at the
Eiffel Tower would not be physically
possible for them to do within that time
frame therefore they would just die of a
heart attack being unable to complete
the task however if light used his death
note and wrote down that say his college
professor would die in two years for
example he could in theory manipulate
the professor to give him an A in his
class as this would count as an action
that is possible for the professor to do
yes see what I'm getting at folks the
point is is that Kira here is not
thinking about the long game so far all
of Kira's death have happened within a
short time frame and this is why the
police and the world noticed it
discovering the identity of this FBI
agent means that he could have used this
he could better serve Kira alive than
Dead Light could ride down the death of
this FBI agent to happen in two years or
even longer than that for example and
this means that for the next two years
or more Kira could control the actions
of this FBI agent to one help him
discover the identities of the rest of
the FBI agents in Japan and two once he
knows all the names and faces of the FBI
agents that are in Japan Kira could
control all of them repeating the same
tactics from early to essentially become
their Puppet Master of the entire FBI
group Sent to Japan and could use them
to discover over L's identity and
eventually take him out this my good
weebs is just one example of how Kira
could have better used his time and his
power this kid is thinking too small and
too short-term and is not thinking of
the bigger picture one week later light
follows the FBI agent into the subway he
goes up behind him and reveals to the
agent that he is Kira and tells him that
he'll kill him if he turns around and
doesn't cooperate light then hands the
agent a package containing some
documents and a communication device
putting on the headphones light orders
the agent to get on the train inside he
figures out the exact number of FBI
agents in Japan and tricks this guy into
riding down the names of all the agents
onto this piece of paper as this poor
poor agent doesn't realize that this
piece of paper belongs to the death note
that he has just sentenced all of his
agents to their death after Kira tells
him to leave the envelope above his head
and to exit the train stepping off the
agent suddenly falls to the floor
crawling and turning around he looks up
to see that light is Kira the FBI agent
eyes later word gets to L that all the
FBI agents in Japan have just been
murdered by Kira and as a result
everybody on the Kira task force
discovered that L has secretly been
investigating them this entire time this
causes most of the members of the team
to quit and now only five people ended
up staying on the Kira task force
however L reveals to these men that he
actually predicted this as he figured
eventually someone would find out which
means that these five men these five are
the people that L can fully trust he
tells them to come meet him at his hotel
and he finally reveals his face and
Brilliant mind to them L tells the
police detectives to call him ryuzaki
from now on for precaution and tells
them to switch off their phones while
they're here he reveals to them that he
suspects that Kira was one of the people
that was being investigated by the FBI
agents before they died since his murder
experiments happened shortly after the
agents arrived in Japan he thinks that
Kira felt threatened by their presence
and this is what caused him to test his
powers on those three Prisoners the the
next morning light begins to worry about
Kira's connection to the bus hijacking
knowing that if Elle finds out that he
can control the actions and deaths of
his victims in specific ways prior to
their actual death L could ruin his
plans for creating a perfect world for
good he then offers to help his mom
deliver some fresh clothes to his dad
and he heads down to the police station
to secretly spy on him but there he
bumps into a woman who claims that she
had some information about the Kira case
and that was her biggest mistake the
receptionist tells her that no one from
the Kira task force is at the station or
available at the moment but that's when
light sets off his master plan and
reveals to this woman that he's the son
of the police chief in charge of the
Kira case and that he can put her in
touch with them once his dad calls him
back so they agree to hang out for a
while while they wait okay this is
insane this mysterious Baddie has the
potential to ruin Kira's entire plan and
him inviting her to hang out in order
for him to figure out what she knows and
her name not only means that Kira is a
certified smooth talking stud but that
this plan in and of itself makes a lot
of sense because being the son of the
lead investigator means that naturally
anyone in that position would be unsure
about some Rando check claiming that she
knows something about a case and it
makes sense to assess her first before
letting her talk to the lead
investigator especially on such a major
crime wouldn't that be the right thing
to do I think so and it's not going to
raise any eyebrows or suspicion towards
light from this act alone but again
light is thinking too small because if
we remember the Death Note can't control
the actions of its victims up until the
point of their death which means that
light never had to try to figure out
this woman's name all he has to do is to
find somebody whose name he does know
which by the way he does and this person
was standing right in front of him
remember when we saw light reaching the
police station it's clear that the
police receptionist already knew light
from beforehand and he knew him bingo
Affairs are Human Weapon here's how
we'll do it using the death note we will
write down that this receptionist will
lie to his co-worker and state that he's
starving and quickly head out of the
police headquarters to go get some food
when in reality he's going to be chasing
after us and flagging down this Baddie
he's going to tell her that he was able
to get a hold of the police chief that
he wants to meet with her immediately
and that he can take her to him we at
this time will leave and the two of them
will walk on the man will take her to a
busy intersection then without her
realizing it he's going to push her into
oncoming traffic killing her instantly
the man will hallucinate the whole thing
and thinks that he's imagined it all and
he's going to head back to the front
desk at the police headquarters but not
before he stops by and grabs his snack
and on the way back he also is going to
die in a car accident in doing this our
surprise problem will be taken care of
as well as the loose end of the man that
we controlled because well the man does
work in a busy busy City so wouldn't be
unheard of for the man to get into a
accident light introduces himself and
discovers This Woman's name and he finds
out that she is at ex-fbi agent she
reveals to him that she suspects that
Kira can kill in ways other than a heart
attack and thinks that the recent bus
hijacking was set up by Kira to gather
the identities of the FBI agents who
recently died and she mentions to light
that her FBI fiancee was on that very
same bus light begins to sweat a bit as
she mentions that her fiance told her
that he revealed his ID to someone on
the bus and she thinks that whoever saw
his ID that day is likely to be Kira
himself the woman tells life that he's
the only one who knows her story right
now and then light pretends to write
something down on his death note right
in front of her and he prepares to watch
her die in a few minutes meanwhile at
the Kira Task Force Headquarters
ryozaki's Butler handsome gadgets to the
police and they receive fake police IDs
to protect their real identities from
Kira along with belts implanted with a
location tracking device back near the
station though light waits for the woman
to die but nothing happens and he
realizes that she just gave him a fake
name just then she tells him that she's
decided to officially report her Theory
to the police and begins to walk back to
the police station now on the clock
light desperately tries to figure out
this woman's name and comes up with the
greatest lie of all time he reveals that
he is in fact a part of the Kira task
force and offers the woman a spot on the
investigation team however he asks to
see some form of official ID first and
she chooses to reveal to him her real
identity and that as you know was her
biggest mistake pretending to write down
her information Kira writes down the
Woman's real name into his death note
sealing her fate and sentencing her to
death and he reveals to her that he is
Kira and the woman is shocked and she
suddenly walks off to die later police
begin scanning camera footage of the FBI
agents who recently died and noticed
something strange in the camera footage
they discover that before he died one of
the FBI agents was spotted carrying an
envelope inside of a train but when he
died that envelope was missing and in
the footage ryuzaki notices something
the FBI agent called Ray Pember was
looking towards the train ryuzaki
suspects that Kira was near this agent
and possibly on the train before he died
and he believes that Kira is now
planning something horrifying suddenly
they also find out that the FBI agent's
fiancee has just gone missing this
startles L and thinks that Kira killed
her because she found a clue about him
and something that could have possibly
broken the investigation wide open Elle
then demands the task force to begin
investigating into the two families that
this FBI agent was looking into before
he died as someone within those families
is likely Kira himself and he reveals
that one of the families he plans to
look into belongs to the police chief
mustache man shocked the police chief
then reluctantly agrees to help the
police spy on his own family and they
put cameras and wiretaps all around his
house including including the toilets
the next day light comes home and
secretly discovers that his house has
been bugged just like he predicted and
he convinces ryuk to help him search for
the locations of all the cameras in the
house normally ryog wouldn't bother to
listen to whatever light told him to do
but ryuk loves apples from the human
world and light told him that he's going
to hold him hostage and not give him any
more apples unless he helps him find all
the cameras and wiretaps in his house
and so the shinigame agrees to help
light L thinks that with all this
they'll be able to find Kira however
thanks to his earlier preparations light
continues to secretly kill people right
under Elle's nose and he pretends to act
like the most regular student in the
whole world okay what is he doing
because right now this situation could
either be Kira's worst or best day
depending on how he places cards
throwing off suspicion by literally
inviting the wolf into the Hen's Nest to
take a look around is a move that takes
a serious set of cajones or a massively
huge ego knowing light it's safe to say
that his confidence at this point is
about to bust open all over the place
and if he isn't careful this is going to
cost him big now acting like any normal
teenager under surveillance is a given
however light here is forgetting one
critical component that could cost him
his identity and the fact is that he is
not like any normal teenager even if we
take out the powers of Kira for a second
light here just from his accolades and
accomplishments alone stands out from
the entirety of the Japanese public he
is already known as being incredibly
intelligent and is one of the smartest
people in the Japanese school system and
this is no secret therefore it is
reasonable to assume that L would have
already known this about light going in
and this means that life was so freaking
focused on acting normal and act like
every other kid that he forgot to act
normal in relation to his own Persona
and going out on dates I mean come on
really all of these actions taken by
light were someone of average intellect
in short light acted way too normal
however if light truly wanted to throw L
off then light should have taken a play
right out of Hannibal's book and thrown
a red herring right in front of L doing
something to mislead or distract L from
noticing what was really going on if
life decided to use his insane
intelligence to steal money online from
people or to commit some kind of
misdemeanor crime that only a genius
could cover up then this would have been
in line with what would have been
expected of light an insanely smart kid
who's bored of school and who has too
much time on his hands but the fact that
he acted so normal makes him stand out
and like I said light is smart he should
have been able to sniff out at least one
camera and you know what he should have
done he should have gone directly to his
father and asked what the hell is going
on light is a very observant person so
isn't it fair to say that he might
notice something amiss on his own I say
he should have tackled the problem
head-on rather than act as if nothing is
happening doing this in front of his
whole family will gain him the sympathy
of his other family members and would
cause them to Rally to his defense now
that the surveillance gig would have
been out in the open light could have
done so much more to avoid suspicion
watching light day after day the police
eventually decide that light's family is
Innocent but L still still suspects
something is off about light a few weeks
later having just graduated high school
light starts his first day at college
and he gives a freshman speech however
he notices a strange person on stage
with him not realizing that this is the
one person out to stop him after the
speech ryuzaki sits down next to light
and he reveals to him that he's ill the
famous detective of the Kira task force
this stuns light as he tries to remain
calm and not show any emotions in case
this is a trap Elvin tells him that he
wants his help on the Kira case since
his father is working on it as well they
agree to meet up again soon and light
heads back home and loses his might he
underestimated L and now he can't kill
him unless he figures out his real name
suddenly changing tactics light plans to
get to know the person known as ryuzaki
and try and figure out who he really is
later the two go for coffee as L
confesses that he thinks that light may
be actually Kira light jokes it off and
L test lights detective skills by
showing him photos of messages left
behind by some of Kira's victims the two
play mind games with each other as Ella
tries to get light to reveal himself as
Kira however he is Amazed by light's
detective skills and he officially asks
like to join the Kara task force where
he'll be able to keep a close eye on him
and investigate him even further
suddenly they get a call from life's
death and find out that he's in the
hospital from working too hard there
light's dad confirms to light that this
kid is L the famous detective and that
they call him ryuzaki as a cover name
light then officially agrees to help
with the Kira case as he secretly plans
to spy on L that night a famous news
agency receives a tape with a set of
instructions to broadcast a message to
the world sent from Kira L's team then
gets word of the horrifying news
broadcast and they hear Kira's distorted
voice on TV along with proof that this
person is in fact Kira himself L quickly
tries to stop the news station from
airing the Kira tape live and this one
dude heads over to the news station in
person but when he gets there he
suddenly dies of a heart attack and the
news then shows his corpse live on TV
forcing Elle and his team to see their
dead partner they're horrified and L now
suspects that Kira is in the area and
can now kill anyone just by seeing their
face okay this is crazy because at this
point we know that someone else is
pretending to be Kira due to their
abrupt new style and tactics and
somewhat unrefined demands and how
they're trying to strong-arm the police
publicly and this person is somehow
killing people even more effectively
than light is so far while at first
glanced this potential second rival
could sound intimidating and dangerous
the presence of a second copycat killer
could actually benefit a light in the
long run and in a big way now while no
ordinary sane citizen would suddenly go
on a crime spree for no reason the
amount of media attention from the news
covering crime-related media could
affect individuals already predisposed
to violence and could send these types
of people over the edge as the news
often sensationalizes topics and this
Kira crime case would no doubt not be
the exception for the same reason as
online clicks and channel ratings it's
no doubt that the Keurig killings have
become the hottest Topic in Japan and
dare I say even the world and it's
likely that you would see some mention
of it everywhere you go this is likely
at least partially the reason why this
second killer has finally appeared now
part of the reason that crime-related
media can't Influence People is due to
the reinforcement that if this person
copies the original crime this will
result in as much attention and even
more publicity as the original crime
received which in and of itself can be a
powerful motivator for individuals who
seek that same level of attention and
this trait is something that light could
use against the copycat Killer by
appealing to the copycat's desire for
fame light could figure out a way to get
in touch with this copycat and use him
or her to be the face of the Kira
killings taking credit for the deaths of
the criminals that light Once Dead
however as stated earlier this person
likely doesn't seem as methodical in
their planning due to the amount of
attention that they've already brought
about onto themselves this is why it is
likely that whatever light does to
manipulate this copycat killer he will
need to keep a close eye on this Fame
loving attention-seeking leech as this
person will likely compromise everything
that light has has worked so hard for if
he isn't careful meanwhile kyota's tape
continues to play live and he demands
that people stop trying to catch him but
suddenly mustache man escaping from the
hospital reaches the news station and he
crashes his car through the entrance
going in he retrieves the carrot tapes
and calls Elle for help L calls the
deputy director of the police to arrange
an escort to help a mustache man Escape
allowing him to head back with the tapes
to the Kira Task Force Headquarters the
next morning Ellen his team reviewed the
tapes to find out the full story and
discover that Kira wants more serious
criminals to be aired on the news so
Kara can judge all of their Fates
publicly and he also wants L and the
deputy director of the police to reveal
their identities on live TV and to begin
working for Kira L is grim at this news
but he tells everyone that they should
let Kira follow through with his plan so
they can learn more about this strange
turn of events L then tells the news
station to air one of the Kira tapes
stating what KIRO will do if the police
refuse to cooperate and the tape then
declares to the war world that the
police have four days to decide whether
Kira will kill either the director of
the police or L himself meanwhile light
watches the news and is surprised at
what Kira has said and he finally
realizes that there is now another Kira
out there who not only supports him but
has the powers of the Shinigami eyes as
well meaning that Kira's greatest threat
is also his greatest Sip and if you
don't want to end up as the world's
biggest symptom like comment let us know
what you liked and of course didn't like
it don't get check out the how to be
playlist down below